bello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa dj e non ci
siamo finalmente tornati sul turbo
dismount e siccome ragazzi siamo
arrivati a 750 mila siti che non
trovando pazzesco per farmi perdonare
ragazzi da questi quattro giorni di
pausa deciso di far uscire allo speciale
750.000 che urla questo solito ragazzi
quindi spero siate contenti è questo ci
stava la cosa che non sapevo che me
l'avete detto voi si può selezionare la
faccia al personaggio di turbo dismount
e indovinate che cosa ho messo per
rendere le macchine più sexy è già lì
poteva modificare anche la faccia del
tizio quindi ho deciso di farlo ho
deciso di metterne una giusta un'altra
cosa che ho scoperto ragazzi che
impedimenti annuncio hanno aggiunto la
visuale in prima persona che una cosa è
una cosa o 19 così non si capisce una
sega
però qualcosa mi dice che mi sono fatto
male e per ragazzi hanno hanno aggiunto
nei veicoli nuovi tipo tipo questo ma
che cazzo è le posizioni più belle che
abbia mai io non ho parole giorno c'è
una cosa stupenda e sculetta pure
la ragazzina è bellissimo cioè io io mi
innamoro sempre di più visto il gioco ma
perché prima già era epico ma così lo è
20 volte di più cosa cosa fai stato maso
questo che poi lega con l'ultimo
aggiornamento è raggiunto un bordello di
livelli tipo tipo questo che non so che
cos'è un parcheggio giusto può sembrare
strano questo gioco ci sono anche i
parcheggi che cazzo parte lo skate che
voglio un accordo al giorno acrobazia
epica con questo esigo la esigo
assolutamente perchè devo devo farle ok
sono finito sotto una macchina perfetto
adesso ho capito perché la piccola
nascondino nomi tra mai nessuno magari
se riuscissi a parcheggiare qua è un
tratto ci sono i trattori giustamente
enac ahec bravo brano scusino nostro
certo già capito discorsi sto cercando
di parcheggiare sim aggiorna stessi
togliere i [ __ ] che cazzo qualche ed
eseguito puoi riuscire a girare prima
via riva bravo
no non dovevi fermati qui lo ammazzo non
ho mai forchia drive è il parcheggio più
bello che abbia mai fatto niente
giusto che poi la mia faccia sulle
portiere e sempre qualcosa è il tocco di
classe praticamente se magari usi la
portiere un po meglio però va bene anche
così ma ma ho fatto la spesa dove le
metto le buste le lascio qui ok perfetto
nel dubbio si portiamo perché il
carrello non si sa mai
ragazzi questa questa devo assolutamente
farlo perché questa bellissima ragazzi
qualcuno mi spiega che cazzo di po cos'è
un kamasutra
ma come cazzo fa partire che non si dà
né a michela spingerlo in parte a caso
senza nasti la spinta non è possibile in
chieti a volte certi sufficienti io non
ho fatto un cazzo
scusate ragazzi non volevo non era mia
intenzione averlo fatto perché ho fatto
casino
ok questo questo è sempre stato il mio
sogno è probabilmente lo farò non ci ho
ripensato a zero non si vede un caso
solo che mi stanno passando addosso di
250 macchine ma non so come rea rende
bout che cazzo era perfetto sono sono
ancora cos'è ragazzi fatevi provare con
la uccello mobile perché devo
assolutamente provarci anche se non ho
ancora capito perché devo grazie no no
grazie grazie mille
devo riuscire ad arrivare a schivare le
macchine la cosa impossibile processo
fare se l'ho fatto ragazzi già fatta non
so come lurido pullman di merda 26
spuntato [ __ ] e belli
non è che io questa voglio io questo
voglio anche chiesto è successo
[Musica]
io dei limiti però non potete farmi ste
cose con lo scherzo dovrei riuscirci
effettivamente credo spero di sì
madonna che affacciato dato che poi sia
maxis certo massima sicuro io voglio
voglio assoluta devo rivederla la
facciata vi prego e ragazzi porca [ __ ]
e che cazzo da me bene anche sbagliato è
colma bellissima e d'aoste io voglio un
oscar per questo gioco rendiamo diamo un
oscar a scuola questa roba ragazzi
qualcuno mi spiega con che magia arcana
riesce a guidare che volante dietro la
cosa mi fa strano non importa
sull'albero minchia meglio di tarzan è
volato è volato ladrona non fa niente
perfetto e un po parcheggiato i ragazzi
parcheggio così magari se riesco a fare
un livello tipo loop dell'op ma che
cazzo è stato come se quella roba
ragazze tu cosa scazzo scudetti ancora
ragazzi questo devo vedevo vederla in
prima persona perché bellissimo dio mi
chiami sta vendendo lavori tare a me non
lo so perché strike drago fatto anche
strike e noi credo ho fatto anche se fai
così dai che ce la fa ragazzi è la cosa
più malsana che abbia mai visto sì certo
e che ci fa un cazzo non è che non mi
sembrava strano eccolo lì perfetto
thylane merger che cos'è sta roba è
un'autostrada è un altro strano questo
volevo fare ragazzi la faccia con col
motorino perché questa demo io dovrei
entrare in autostrada in motorino e
facciamolo più messi dei ragazzi eccoli
perfetto
devi fare una curva
no niente e chi è più difficili fatto
sempre perché giustamente magari guidare
coi piedi non è
nel massimo magari andiamo così perché
meglio merci così cosa fa
madonna quanto sei sforzo ragazzi vanno
con lo skate perché normalmente non ci
si può ri e con questo ci riesco adesso
voi vi spiegate com'è possibile che con
lo skate ci riesco e col motorino no
cazzo e [ __ ] però anche tornerà
bella sì c'è un'altra grazie grazie
grazie grazie mille all'ora bye bye bye
bye no ma che cazzo come ho fatto a
tornare sullo skate come fatto a tornare
sullo skate e poi perché s'è messo a
fare la [ __ ] in mezzo alla tua strada
ma poi abbiamo capito che con lo skate
faccio più danni che altro
cazzo non mi non mi ha preso io ho visto
solo un camion chiama arrivava addosso e
questo è bastato
c'è questa questa devo arrivare alla
fine della strada certo ragazzi che
qualche buon angelo ci accompagni perché
sono finisce malissimo
ok ok ok una sega amico mio l'angelo non
lo dovevi fare tu cazzo
bravo bravo no no è ma che cazzo su una
macchina c'era porca [ __ ] io proverei
ancora questa perché mi sembra la
migliore di tutte giustamente guidare
col sedile la cosa migliore
l'obiettivo era non prendere neanche una
macchina io lo prese tutte tutte cazzo
anche quella lurido stronzo di ma ne
vanno alla 6 caso basta sono rimasto col
manubrio è una cosa oddio caccia marca
motorino senza manubrio legale senza
manubrio stata ecco lo sapevo
senza manovre non puoi andare lontano
scusatemi ma ragazzi e dire che posso
concludere qui l'episodio perché è stato
ben saldo basta comunque ho scoperto non
ci sono un casino di mode di sto gioco
quindi non avete ancora visto
praticamente niente quindi aspettatevi
di tutto perché mi sono trattenuto in
questa puntata è tanto con creati
apposta il fatto che personaggio già le
dette e la mia faccia sul cruscotto e
qualche qualcosa di leggendario io direi
che posso concludere qui l'episodio
ragazzi con l'ultima prova a casa sei
video è piaciuto come se il calcio per
il momento di piacere a carmela di
facebook e come li vide protagonisti già
ne sarebbe cities chiellini ci
clicchiamo quasi amico bello ragazzi